get the dough get the pizza sauce the
international pizza expo is back we're
told that thousands are in town for what
could be the biggest pizza convention in
the entire world hector he has been out
there all morning
tossing dough talking about pizza ovens
that start automatically what's the
latest hector
yeah we've been tossing a lot of a dough
this morning so we're learning how to uh
do a little bit of some acrobatics right
this is seiler who's gonna show us
exactly how he does this and tosses us
into the air so this is part of the tell
us the pizza games right that the world
pizza games here and one of the
competitions is the acrobatic shows so
we're gonna actually teach him how to
take it and roll it down his back how is
this part of the pizza of the pizza expo
so this is great for advertising in your
restaurant we always toss pizza dough
right so how cool is it to do tricks
with the kids in the restaurants so it's
real simple you hold in your hands
flick it down your back and catch it hey
there it is
that is awesome not bad for your first
time this friday he will be at the local
uh pizza rock working the line back
there to help out sorry about that
you're gonna have to go to work now i
guess i have to tell us about the
convention you guys are finally back
after taking a pause last year yeah and
it's so exciting to see everybody back
in the mix and being back to what we
love you know
the camaraderie
hanging out with everybody picking new
ideas seeing what's new in the in the
in the industry what what new
you know the manufacturers are building
stuff to streamline our cooking process
and you know with employment being a
hard thing right now this is great for
us to see what's coming up and what's
new and
they even have robotics people making
pizzas now it's yeah it's like machines
sitting here making all this robots
making pizza really robots making pizza
and it's a thing so
it's just good to be back with all our
you know our big pizza family here so
there's a lot to look forward to for you
personally what are you most looking
forward to as you're coming back to the
convention
i'm i'm
beside seeing our friends obviously
i'm ready to see some new products out
here you know the vegan game is getting
very big and so there's some really
great product that even hormel has come
out with
a pepperoni of vegan pepperoni and it is
phenomenal vegan pepperoni and i was
just kidding earlier about it there's
actually a vegan pepperoni there is a
vegan pepperoni and you when you leave
here you got to go try it it's amazing
and the you know the new things that are
coming up that the pizza guys haven't
been able to bring onto their menu this
is huge for the future for pizza
all right so i'm gonna stay here all
morning even throughout the afternoon
learn a little bit more about the dough
and the vegan pepperoni for now
reporting live hector mejia and let's
see some of your uh fantastic dough
skills seiler there you go sally you see
styler there he's going to be part of
the competition later on today
look at those moves all right reporting
live hector mejia and seiler and his
awesome moves we'll send it back to you
guys could be an olympic event and we
can't wait for the gluten-free pizza
hector john
thank you nate thank you hector good
stuff there very tasty